10dans giscard d'estaing en espagne pour
quatre jours en batterie pour une équipe
de reportage d'antenne 2 le smic + 3 8 %
raymond barre le redressement économique
doit profiter aux plus défavorisés
europe
françois mitterrand chez le président de
la république au milieu de la semaine
prochaine
cambodge vietnam une guerre larvée
toutes les conditions réunies pour un
nouveau conflit en indochine
voir nous voici donc à madrid devant le
palais royal c'est ici que dans une
heure le roi d'espagne en oeuvre a dit
les valéry giscard d'estaing
les entretiens prévus sur une durée
totale de quatre heures réparties sur
les quatre jours que doit durer ce
voyage officiel c'est peu de dire qu'il
s'agit d'une visite historique depuis
1906 depuis le président de la
république emile loubet aucun chef de
l'état français ne s'étaient rendu ici
de ce côté des pyrénées le général de
gaulle avait bien fait le voyage à
madrid 70 69
il n'était plus chef de l'état il avait
serré la main d'un autre général franck
n'était pas la seule raison pour
laquelle nous avons déplacé aux caméras
une partie de l'équipe de ce journal
c'est aussi parce qu'il se passe ici
depuis deux ans et demi depuis la mort
de franco des choses étonnantes pour ne
pas dire admirable pour qui aime un peu
la démocratie et sur lesquels nous
allons revenir dans un instant mais tout
d'abord le résumé de la première journée
de ce voyage avec l'arrivée de valéry
giscard d'estaing il y a trois heures et
demie
à 16 heures 30 précises sous un chaud
soleil le dc-8 présidentielle se pose à
l'aéroport de matt reeves valéry giscard
d'estaing et son épouse sont accueillis
par le roi juan carlos et par la reine
sophie une cérémonie très simple qui ne
durera qu'un quart d'heure ce voyage
officiel et d'abord pour le chef de
l'état un témoignage de l'estimé et de
l'amitié du peuple français pour le
peuple espagnol sympathie réciproque
puisque juan carlos déclaré hier que
l'espagne accueillera son voisin les
bras ouverts et que lui-même
renouvellerait les liens personnels qui
l'unissent au président français cette
visite commence donc sous le triple
signe de l'amitié de la confiance et du
respect après les hymnes nationaux
valéry giscard d'estaing et juan carlos
passe en revue un détachement de l'armée
de l'air avant de saluer le premier
ministre adolfo suarez et le
gouvernement espagnol au grand complet
à lédar en trois sets le premier
entretien officiel va commencer entre
les deux hommes sur le plan politique
peu ou pas de gros problèmes sur le plan
économique en revanche tout ne va pas
pour le mieux entre paris et madrid 1er
canton cieux le déficit commercial
français vis-à-vis de l'espagne il a
triplé en trois ans atteignant 1
milliard 500 millions de francs l'année
dernière mais l'achat de 48 mirage f1
par madrid devrait contribuer à le
réduire
deuxième contentieux le plus important
les problèmes posés à l'agriculture
française par l'entrée de l'espagne dans
le marché commun ici tout est à faire ou
presque
les quatre heures d'entretiens qu'auront
les deux hommes pourrait permettre de
débloquer la situation dans les jardins
du palais royal
depuis une semaine depuis samedi le roi
les a ouverts au public
nous devions un petit peu destin est
venu ici en grand frère il ya deux ans
et demi il avait donné un sérieux coup
de pouce aux jeunes rois en assistant à
son couronnement et en ne ménageant pas
son soutien à la démocratie encore un
petit peu balbutiante espagnols dont on
ne savait pas trop comment elle allait
tourner pari réussi 10 aujourd'hui les
observateurs
le roi a gagné voyez vous la semaine
dernière la commission parlementaire
chargée d'élaborer la constitution qui
sera soumise à référendum donc à tout le
monde à l'automne prochain
cette commission a terminé ses travaux
et on ya vu y travailler côte à côte un
communiste catalan est un ancien
ministre de franco
depuis les élections c'est à dire depuis
un an tout juste presque jour pour jour
on assiste à une cohabitation paisible
des quatre grandes forces politiques de
ce pays
les socialistes un bon tiers en hausse
en ce moment les centristes derrière le
premier ministre adolfo suarez également
un bon tiers
les communistes 10 à 15% la droite 5 à
10%
le tout grâce à l'habileté à la sagesse
d'un homme
juancarlos felipe de bourbon
succédera à son père le roi juan carlos
le projet de nouvelle constitution le
prévoit monarchiste les espagnols n'ont
pas vraiment mais en deux ans et demi
les républicains les plus viscéraux sont
devenus franchement juan carr liste
c'est que ce souverain en la personne de
qui franco voulait rétablir la monarchie
a su surprendre et c'est vide
on ignorait ce que pensent et ce
militaire gradé plus haut niveau dans
les trois armes
certains avaient même prédit sa chute
plus ou moins rapides plus ou moins
brutale
on avait connu de lui que le jeune homme
timide puis un successeur désigné effacé
derrière la personnalité du vieux
dictateur
on oublie que ce soldat complet
contrôlera à lui seul le comportement de
l'armée dans la période de transition
qui suivra la dictature en oublieront
d'effacement politique observée du
vivant de franco lui aura permis de le
jour venu d'apparaître comme un homme
neuf
alors qu juancarlos s'installe au
pouvoir
il est entouré d'hommes qui doute de son
avenir
mais à l'étranger le jeune souverain à
un ami valéry giscard d'estaing le
président lui a offert cette amitié le
jour de son couronnement
valéry giscard d'estaing le français et
walder shell l'allemand sont les seuls
chefs d'état européens à s'être déplacés
à cette occasion giscard et le roi se
revoient à paris où juan carlos est reçu
en visite officielle en espagne on a
toujours regardé avec intérêt ce qui se
passe en france
maintenant c'est la france qui se fit
avec sympathie ce qui se passe en
espagne et qui le dit aujourd'hui plus
personne dans le monde ne conteste au
roi et à son premier ministre les
résultats qu'ils ont obtenus et la
constitution qui s'élabore fera de la
nouvelle espagne une monarchie
parlementaire dans laquelle juancarlos
jouera le rôle d'un chef d'état leroy
gouvernera moins que ne l'aurait voulu
les absolutistes bien plus que ne le
souhaitaient les républicains la
nouvelle espagne vient de fêter un an de
liberté politique retrouvé le 15 juin 77
avec les élections générales et le
personnage clé reste juan carlos 1er roi
de l'espagne démocratique
bien sûr il serait absurde de tout
peindre en rose l'espagne traverse de
réelles difficultés économiques
un million de chômeurs c'est à dire un
chiffre comparable à la france mais pour
une population de 36 millions
d'habitants
une inflation record 26 pour cent
soixante-dix-sept un taux ramené aux
alentours de 16% cette année par les
effets d'un plan d'assainissement une
dévaluation de 22% l'an dernier une
croissance zéro il ya aussi les
problèmes politiques
le statut de près autonomie accordée aux
différentes provinces et qui résoudra en
partie le problème catalan n'empêche pas
la pesée basque de se gonfler et là qui
sait tout peut arriver
fadi on respire à madrid on respire un
air de liberté
à preuve ce foisonnement incroyable de
la presse 2400 mensuel 330 bimensuel 830
hebdomadaire et près de 200 quotidiens
qui aujourd'hui titre la plupart sur la
visite de valéry giscard d'estaing à
madrid
et puis s'il faut une autre preuve de ce
vent de liberté avec tout ce que cela
suppose d'humour regardez ce qui s'est
passé hier dans le musée grévin
hélène adolfo suarez
il y avait aussi felipe gonzalez le
leader socialiste
et puis tout naturellement juancarlos
denis à sofia et les infos d'espagne il
y a maintenant et depuis hier
santiago carillo à la gauche de la
famille royale
je crois que m et celle ci doit avoir
des personnages qui sont connus par le
public
les gens ici me voir alors les
politiques sont très populaires des
pieds à la tête
santiago carillo a contribué à assurer
l'authenticité de son personnage il a
fourni tous les vêtements et les
accessoires à une seule exception près
puis la patte derrière ses lunettes et
ses incidences et un employé à nous
qu'il a donnée le net pour jouer et
c'est une conscience qu'il n'est pas
communiste il était communiste parce
qu'il a vécu à kouba fallait pas plus la
sortie de cuba elle est assez réussie
mais enfin j'ai trouvé là un sourire
figé il n'a pas bien su rester simple et
sympathique la garde le sourire de 5 0
et est connue en espagne face à la
probable non non non non non non je dis
ce que les gens disent je me répète
et puis en plus j'ai limon que sa
cigarette chose qu'on dit aussi car dans
l'ensemble c'est parlera le lit qui est
assez difficile à fait parce qu'il
allait assez bien de santiago carillo
aux côtés de pablo picasso ou de jimmy
carter permet
mesurer le degré de respectabilité
atteint par le parti communiste en
espagne et s'il fallait encore s'en
convaincre il suffirait d'ajouter que
santiago carrillo a fait son entrée ici
avant franco le mannequin du car audio
sera présenté au public madrilène que la
semaine prochaine il ya tous ces
personnages tous les espagnols en tout
cas on va les retrouver ce soir en chair
et en os
aux côtés de valérie giscard d'estaing
de juan carlos les numéro un communiste
et socialiste seront là en smoking les
invités du roi d'espagne
nous vous en parlerons dans notre
dernier journal pour une as noches comme
disent les génériques de la télévision
espagnole
et maintenant pour le reste de
l'actualité à paris et dans l'est de
l'étranger patrick lecocq retour en
france en effet où le ciel vous avez pu
le remarquer tout au long de cette
journée n'avait pas la clarté du ciel
madrilène on n'y peut rien chez nous il
ne fait pas beau et la météo n'est pas
très optimiste pour demain nous verrons
cela bien sûr à la fin de cette édition
les leaders de l'opposition seront reçus
à l'elysée la semaine prochaine monsieur
mitterrand et de faire pour le parti
socialiste ainsi que messieurs marché et
ballanger pour le parti communiste ont
reçu une invitation pour mercredi
prochain
les deux leaders socialistes feront le
déplacement de l'elysée mais le parti
communiste ne sera représentée que par
monsieur ballanger monsieur georges
marchais est en effet absent de france
au jour choisi par le président de la
république monsieur giscard d'estaing
aura reçu la veille c'est à dire mardi
les responsables de la majorité udf et
rpr
cette série de consultations aura pour
thème le prochain sommet des grands pays
industrialisés
un sommet qui se tiendra à bonn à la mi
juillet cette rencontre est aussi comme
le souligne l'elysée la confirmation de
ce qu'avait dit et des intentions
exprimées par le président de la
république lors de sa conférence de
presse le 14 juin dernier le chef de
l'état lors du conseil qui s'est tenu ce
matin à l'elysée le conseil des
ministres a d'ailleurs estimé que les
résultats des dernières élections
démontré que l'opinion publique que
comprenait et approuvé l'actuelle
politique de renouvellement et
d'ouverture mais lors de ce conseil il a
surtout été question du smic un nouveau
taux horaire a été adopté un taux
horaire qui correspond à un salaire de
1888 francs par mois pour 40 heures de
travail par semaine devant les caméras
de télévision
monsieur raymond barre a d'ailleurs
expliqué sa politique
qu'en matière de bas salaires vous allez
l'entendre mais auparavant je vous
propose de revenir à l'aide de chiffres
et de graphiques sur ce nouveau smic
l'élévation des prix en mai a donc été
de 1% chiffre assez proche de celui des
deux mois précédents
c'est bien sûr la série d'augmentation
des tarifs publics qui a le plus pesé
sur cette hausse le coût de la vie
mesurée par l'indicé officiel a ainsi
progressé de 9% par rapport à l'an
dernier même époque
c'est à 10 assez élevé comporte une
conséquence qui intéresse des centaines
de milliers de français puisqu'il
entraîne aux termes de la loi une
réévaluation automatique du smic
l'ancien valeur était au 1er mai 10
francs 45 l'heure elle est remontée de 3
8%
la nouvelle valeur au 1er juillet est
donc un peu plus élevé que la stricte
application de la loi qui accroche le
smic analyse des prix 10 francs 85
l'heure soit à peu près 1887 francs par
mois comme il l'avait fait en mai le
gouvernement à donner le petit coup de
pouce supplémentaire qui remonte un peu
la courbe vers le haut dans le cadre de
la politique de pouvoir d'achat puis
raymond barre a précisé une nouvelle
fois aujourd'hui à la sortie du conseil
des ministres pour un départ et
septembre 1976 c'est à dire le moment où
le gouvernement a engagé la politique de
redressement et oui il a dit que cette
politique ne se ferait pas aux dépens
des catégories les plus défavorisées
je vous signale que le minimum
vieillesse a augmenté de 40 et 1,2 pour
cent depuis septembre 1976 ce qui fait
une progression de pouvoir d'achat de 19
3% que le smic a augmenté de 26,5 pour
cent ce qui fait une augmentation de
pouvoir d'achat de 6 8% que les
prestations familiales ont augmenté de
26,2 pour cent ce qui fait une
augmentation de pouvoir d'achat de 6 6%
dans le même temps le taux de salaire
horaire a augmenté de 22% et en pouvoir
d'achat de 3 %
autrement dit les prestations familiales
et le smic ont augmenté en pouvoir
d'achat du double du taux de salaire
horaire et en ce qui concerne les
pensions de retraite et le minimum
vieillesse
les hausses de pouvoir d'achat ont été
de 11% et d'en vivre
20% j'aimerais ministre en ce qui
concerne les prix la nuit du bad mais
des pas très bon il n'est pas non plus
très beau mais comment l'avez-vous
accueilli écouter pour moi un indice
n'est pas toujours très beau très
mauvais un indice le résultat de
facteurs objectifs nous connaissons je
dirais qu'il ya un élément favorable
dans l' indice de du mois de mai c'est
que si l'on tient compte de la hausse
des tarifs publics qui se répercute dans
l' indice l'ensemble des prix n'augmente
que de 0 6%
nous aurons encore en juillet et en août
des indices élevés
par exemple au mois d'août nous aurons
la répercussion complète de la hausse du
prix de l'essence mais c'est un
phénomène inéluctable car si on
augmentait taëf ubi le prix de l'essence
où les prix des produits agricoles à
suite décisions sont intervenus à
bruxelles l' indice des prix augmente
ce que je voudrais dire c'est que
l'évolution profonde des prix en france
n'est pas aussi dramatique
on veut bien le dire et je crois que les
ajustements nécessaires ayant été fait
nous retrouverons d'ici la fin de
l'année une évolution satisfaisante nous
prie monsieur conditions une politique
sociale et économique on a remarqué ici
ou là quelques mouvements de mauvaise
humeur alors ne craignez-vous pas à la
rentrée après les vacances une
convergence des irritations le pays
comprend la nécessité des mesures qui
sont prises et j'espère que la politique
qui est menée pourra conduire à ce qui
est le seul objectif du gouvernement
le redressement de notre économie la
sauvegarde du niveau de vie et à terme
la reprise d'une expansion qui assure un
niveau d'emploi aussi satisfaisant que
possible la voie à suivre est une voie
difficile parfois dur mais si nous la
suivons sylvain suivons avec courage
nous en nous bénéficierons des fruits de
l'effort qui aura été entrepris
je ne sais pas si ses propos de monsieur
raymond barre auront convaincu
totalement les responsables de
l'opposition en tout cas monsieur
laurent fabius du parti socialiste a
très durement critiqué cet après midi à
l'assemblée nationale le premier
ministre vous êtes le premier
inflationniste de france a déclaré le
député socialiste
jusqu'où et surtout jusqu'à quand allez
vous poursuivre cette politique qui
porte atteinte au niveau de vie de
millions de français
un thème sur lequel est également revenu
lors d'une conférence de presse monsieur
françois mitterrand après avoir annoncé
que le parti socialiste pensais tout
lancement d'un journal quotidien et
avoir réaffirmé que le premier
secrétaire et la direction du ps avait
bien l'intention de poursuivre leur
tâche
monsieur mitterrand a critiqué et la
politique du gouvernement on pourrait
dire qu'après tout monsieur bart a
échoué on pourrait dire que monsieur
chirac a échoué je crois qu'il serait
beaucoup plus simple de dire parce que
ce serait plus juste qu'après tout
monsieur giscard d'estaing n'a pas cessé
d'échouer
quelle que soit la représentation le
visage ou le masque ou la libye qu'il a
choisi pour dissimuler sa propre
responsabilité
pendant longtemps monsieur giscard
d'estaing à penser que le premier
financier de france c'était monsieur
giscard d'estaing il semble avoir changé
d'avis il a pensé ensuite que l'homme
fort de son système sur et monsieur
chirac qui la trouvaient trop fort avant
de ses forces et par une série de
banderilles de l'affaiblir et maintenant
et là estimé que monsieur bart été le
meilleur économiste de france réunissait
le premier financier l'homme fort du
système et le meilleur économiste et
jugeait le résultat et vous verrez à ce
moment là que les ressources de
vocabulaire tienne lieu de politique
pour la france
toujours dans ce domaine la réaction du
rpr monsieur tour de la baie a réaffirmé
qu aux yeux plus
br il serait souhaitable de procéder à
l'automne à des relances dans certains
secteurs économiques comme la sidérurgie
par exemple mais le rpr aujourd'hui
s'est aussi prononcé sur le financement
des partis politiques proposées par le
chef de l'état dans sa conférence de
presse du 14 juin
selon monsieur claude labbé les députés
du parti de monsieur chirac ne pourrait
accepter qu'un contrôle obligatoire de
ce financement et puis autre événement
de cette journée politique un événement
à venir puisqu'il aura pour cadre ce
soir antenne 2 à 21h30 jean pierre
elkabbach et alain duhamel accueille
dans cartes sur table madame jeannette
torres vermeersch la veuve de maurice
thorez
on comprend ainsi un silence de près de
dix années dix ans des silences en effet
c'était en 1968
jallet torres vermeersch démissionné de
ses fonctions de responsable et leur
devenait une simple militante
la veuve de maurice thorez ne mettait
pas que le parti communiste ait pu
désapprouvé l'invasion de la
tchécoslovaquie par l'ours elle qui
symbolise la période stalinienne du
parti communiste et qui s'est opposé en
1968 à ce qui fut l'une des étapes les
plus spectaculaires de son évolution
quel jugement va-t-elle porter sur ces
dix années écoulées l'union de la gauche
le programme commun la rupture l'échec
électoral
elle qui ne désapprouve est pas
l'écrasement du printemps de prague que
pense-t-elle aujourd'hui des remous qui
agitent le parti communiste opposant la
direction à ceux qui voudraient en son
sein davantage de liberté telle est sans
doute l'intérêt politique de ce cartes
sur table mais je n'ai de werner ce
n'est pas seulement une militante
nous l'avons vu hier dans notre journal
c'est aussi une femme qui parle de
l'amour avec les sourires de l'art et de
l'histoire des hommes avec patio cartes
sur table donc ce soir à 21h30 dans une
heure et 10 minutes environ pour
maintenant la grève s'étend dans les
arsenaux français à toulon les
travailleurs de l'arsenal qui avait
repris le travail hier ont à nouveau
quitter leur atelier
ce matin et à brest où la grève dure
maintenant depuis trois semaines la
détermination des ouvriers de l'arsenal
ne s'émousse pas le dialogue pourtant
n'est pas rompu entre les syndicats et
le ministère de la défense une première
réunion s'est tenue aujourd'hui
et puis sachez encore que le chef de
l'état vient d'écrire aux recteurs mal
le président du mouvement universel de
la responsabilité scientifique monsieur
giscard d'estaing demande dans cette
lettre que soit entreprise une réflexion
sur l'évolution du monde lit
à celle des sciences et des techniques
une vaste enquête va donc être lancé
dans un an
une synthèse sera fêté une rencontre
hommes de science hommes politiques
pourraient être envisagées les français
ne payent pas leurs amants de la gestion
des universités est particulièrement
hasardeuse on gaspille beaucoup dans les
hôpitaux
la cour des comptes a rendu aujourd'hui
son verdict depuis ce matin le chef de
l'état a sur son bureau un volumineux
dossier un dossier qu'il retrouve
d'ailleurs chaque année
cette année les des critiques de la cour
des comptes porte moins sur les
irrégularités classiques que sur le flou
qui existe dans les relations entre
l'état les collectivités et les
entreprises
attention donc aux gaspillages dans les
hôpitaux attention à la gestion du
personnel universitaire dans ce secteur
il y aurait paraît-il trop d'heures
supplémentaires cumulées avec les
rémunérations attention aux stations de
sports d'hiver également il y a trop
d'opérations mal conçue et mal réalisés
trop de municipalités croulant sous les
créances par faute de gestion
et puis dans ce traditionnel rapport il
y a aussi des surprises
c'est ainsi que 10% seulement des
français paieraient leurs contraventions
au moins à paris en province les
automobilistes ont beaucoup plus de sens
civique
il est vrai aussi sans vouloir excuser
les parisiens qu'il est probablement
plus facile de se garer à la campagne
que sur les champs-elysées où je le
rappelle le stationnement est interdit
vous ne trouverez pas le quotidien de
paris dans les kiosques demain vous ne
le trouverez pas non plus les jours
suivants le quotidien cesse de paraître
c'est son directeur philippe tesson qui
a pris cette décision à la suite des
difficultés financières que connaissait
son journal est aussi d'une grève
déclenchée par une partie de la
rédaction
cette réunion doit avoir pour but nous
demander notre avis sur la procédure de
licenciement qui est engagée
2h30 ce matin des rotatives pour une
dernière et ultime édition le
quotidienne paris n'aura désormais plus
le bonheur d'être ni la joie de paraître
malade depuis sa naissance il ya quatre
ans seulement mais moribond depuis trop
longtemps déjà le quotidien des
intellectuels non conformiste tombe à
son tour victime de finances trop
fragile après une grève d'avertissement
de 24 heures des journalistes cfdt
pourtant minoritaire dans l'entreprise
philippe tesson le directeur du
quotidien a choisi de cesser
immédiatement la parution
plutôt que d'avoir à faire face je cite
à une série de revendications en chaîne
des revendications qu'ils jugent
inopinés et abusive
notre arrêt de travail n'était pas un
ultimatum expliquent les grévistes et
nous voulions simplement obtenir
l'ouverture de négociations pour évoquer
le problème des moyens et de la survie
du journal survie du journal il était
déjà un peu tard
depuis la parution du journal le matin
le quotidien de paris avait perdu près
de la moitié de ces acheteurs sans
soutien financier extérieur
il n'est pas facile de faire vivre et
survivre un journal qui se veut
indépendant
aujourd'hui le quotidien de paris en est
mort alors jean françois kahn le
quotidien de paris encore un journal qui
disparaît des kiosques
je ne sais pas si le public s'en rend
bien compte mais pour nous journalistes
les journalistes de toutes opinions
la disparition du quotidien de paris une
disparition de plus c'est une petite
tragédie car voyez-vous l journal qui
meurt c'est un petit peu de la liberté
de la presse
timmer de la même façon qu'une feuille
jaunie qui tombe d'un arbre cela annonce
toujours d'une certaine manière un
automne
et puis le quotidien de paris s'était
pas tout à fait un journal comme les
autres dans cette société
couper en 2 qu'est la nôtre fractionné
en sectes en chapelle où les uns veulent
ignorer les autres c'était
une passerelle fragile entre les les
deux moitiés de la france d'ailleurs on
disait tantôt du quotidien de paris
qu'il était socialiste ou gauchiste
tantôt qu'il était jusque ardien ou aux
chiraquiens
c'était un peu son honneur c'était la
preuve de sa diversité
en fait je peux en témoigner il était et
tout cela et rien de cela
sa vocation voyez vous c'était je crois
d'exprimer un peu le sentiment de tous
ceux qui ne se sent pas totalement est
pleinement à l'aise dans leur camp ou
dans leurs églises respectives de droite
ou de gauche
c'était je crois sa grandeur peut-être
est-ce que cela a été aussi la raison de
sa perte
peut-être finalement les lecteurs
désire-t-il être confortés dans leurs
croyances et leurs certitudes
oui si un journal moeurs et qu'il n'a
plus le lecteur ou pas assez de lecteurs
pour vivre le vietnam et le cambodge
sont ils à nouveau entrer dans la guerre
ce matin cela semblait pratiquement
certain selon certaines informations on
apprenait en effet que le vietnam avait
lancé une offensive depuis une quinzaine
de jours contre le cambodge offensive
menée par soixante dix mille hommes
environ appuyée par des chars est
l'aviation ce soir
le doute s'installe il est presque
certain que des combats opposent
vietnamiens et cambodgiens
mais les effectifs est en jeu de part et
d'autre pourraient être beaucoup plus
restreint que ceux annoncés dans la
matinée
c'était il ya quelques semaines à la
frontière des deux pays si les soldats
vietnamiens
de retour d'une mission en territoire
cambodgien depuis presque un an
maintenant des accrochages très
meurtriers ont eu lieu pratiquement
chaque jour entre les deux armées
mais ce soir les spécialistes militaires
les plus sérieux ne peuvent affirmer
avec certitude qu'une grande offensive
est était d'en déclencher sur le
cambodge par les troupes vietnamiennes
reste que si l'affrontement militaire
entre plein de peine et hanoi n'a pas
lieu en ce moment la tension n'a jamais
été aussi vivant entre les deux pays
reste qu'une nouvelle fois ce conflit
larvé illustre bien la bataille que se
livrent les deux géants union soviétique
et chine par vietnam et cambodge
interposés
les alliés d'hier unis contre
l'intervention américaine sont
aujourd'hui sur le point de déclencher
une nouvelle guerre d'indochine
toutes les conditions semblent réunies
ici
en sports françoise burg s'est qualifiée
cet après midi il s'agit de tennis pour
le 2e tour du simple dames de wimbledon
une qualification très facile 6 1 6 0
françoise durr affrontait l'uruguayenne
fiorella botticelli les sportifs vont
d'ailleurs continuer à être gâtés après
les tennismans à roland garros et
maintenant à wimbledon après la coupe du
monde de football
c'est au champion cycliste d'entrer en
scène pendant 24 jours ils vont ainsi
tourner tout autour de notre pays demain
ils seront cent dix au départ du 65ème
tour de france 22 étapes au total avec
un prologue dès demain sur 5 km 200 au
départ de l'iden en hollande
pendant ce tour noter aussi qu'il y aura
quatre étapes contre la montre et
l'ascension de huit cols de première
catégorie et de cinq cols de deuxième
catégorie
l'étape phare de ce 65e tour le tour de
france part dont grenoble morzine avec
sept cols dont trois de première
catégorie c'est peut-être là que le tour
se jouera
et puis je m'aperçois que j'ai oublié de
vous parler de l'événement de cette
journée le mariage est oui caroline de
monaco princesse de son étape est devenu
aujourd'hui madame juno une cérémonie
civile
aujourd'hui le mariage religieux aura
lieu demain obtenez allons voir dans la
principauté si tout cela s'est très bien
passé
voulez vous prendre pour mal monsieur
philippe riche français ce jeunot ici
présents
aujourd'hui à monte carlo il relaie
jouer le rouge et le blanc la
principauté pavoiser pour être pour le
grand spectacle marie la fille aînée
caroline louise marc cherry qui donne
son coeur à philippe junot que s'en
fallut que ne pleurera ce les princes
dans les cours d'europe
la passion selon carole et une passe par
un français de 38 ans au milieu de la
jet society qui a conçu et qui a
consenti à lui mais ses réacteurs pour
venir ici brillé de tous ses feux
pour le meilleur caroline était en robe
empire pour recevoir les rois une
berthod d'italie michel de roumanie
le comte de paris celui de barcelone
liliane de suède sans oublier la gac ans
et le tout hollywood
caroline devenue l'épousé de philippe
junot conseiller en investissement
auprès d'un groupe de banques aura à
présent à lui rendre des comptes et
philippe piat soir le 7 août et la météo
pour demain nous annonce un temps très
nuageux avec sur la moitié nord de la
france avec même quelques pluies sur les
régions méditerranéennes et le sud des
alpes le temps sera ensoleillé et entre
ces deux régions il sera si je puis dire
mi figue mi raisin c'est de dire nuageux
avec de belles éclaircies goulet
températures elles resteront toujours
aussi fraîche voilà cette édition
franco-espagnole de notre journal de 20
heures est terminée à 22h35 c'est gérard
holtz qui vous présentera notre dernier
journal quant à moi je vous retrouve
demain soir bonne soirée à tous